Pessoal, qual é o melhor tipo de
vitamina B12? Seria metilcobalamina,
hidroxicobalamina ou adenosilcobalamina?
Hoje eu quero bater o papo sobre um
assunto que vive aparecendo no
consultório e que gera muita confusão na
cabeça das pessoas. Sabe quando você vai
na manipulação na farmácia comum comprar
B12 e o farmacêutico te mostra três
opções diferentes com nomes complicados
e você fica ali parado, sem saber qual
escolher? Pois é, hoje vamos complicar
isso de uma vez por todas. Imagina só,
outro dia chegou no consultório uma
paciente super antenada, daquelas que
pesquisam tudo na internet antes da
consulta e ela entrou na sala já
disparando. Doutor, eu li que tem
metilcobalamina, hidroxicobalamina,
adenosilcobalamina e qual que é melhor?
A minha amiga toma uma, meu personal
trainer indicou outra. E agora? Olha, eu
adorei a pergunta dela porque é
exatamente isso que nós vamos
esclarecer. Primeiro, vamos entender uma
coisa básica. Todas essas palavras
complicadas são simplesmente formas
diferentes da mesma vitamina B12. É como
se fosse irmãs da mesma família. Cada
uma tem a sua personalidade, suas
características próprias, mas no final
das contas todas são B12. E o mais legal
é que o nosso corpo é tão inteligente
que consegue trabalhar com todas elas,
transformando uma na outra conforme a
necessidade. A vitamina B12 é produzida
exclusivamente por bactérias. Sabia
disso? Acho que não, né? Isso mesmo. Nem
plantas, nem animais conseguem fabricar
essa vitamina. As bactérias que vivem no
intestino dos animais é que fazem esse
trabalho. Por isso que a B12 está
presente principalmente em alimentos de
origem animal. Curioso, não é? Agora
vamos conhecer cada uma dessas formas,
começando pela metilcobalamina. Essa é a
queridinha do pessoal que busca suporte
pro cérebro e sistema nervoso. Sabe por
quê? Porque ela consegue atravessar a
barreira hematoencefálica ou
hematooicórica. Aquela proteção que o
nosso cérebro tem para filtrar o que
entra, o que não entra. É como se ela
tivesse um passe VIP pro cérebro. A
metocobalamia, então é fundamental nos
processos de metilação do nosso corpo.
Calma, não se assusta com esse tema.
Ventilação é simplesmente o processo
pelo qual nosso corpo adiciona grupinhos
químicos em várias moléculas para elas
funcionarem direitinho. É tipo colocar o
tempero certo na comida para ela ficar
gostosa. Esse processo é essencial para
produzir neurotransmissores, formar a
bainha de mielina dos nervos e até para
desintoxicar o organismo. Muita gente me
pergunta sobre o tal do gene MTHFR.
Olha, é verdade que quem tem certas
variações nesse gene pode se beneficiar
mais ainda da mitocobalamina, mas não é
regra absoluta. Cada caso é um caso e a
gente precisa avaliar o contexto todo do
paciente. Agora nós vamos falar da
adenozil cobalamina,
também conhecido como cobamida. Essa é a
forma que trabalha dentro das nossas
mitocôndrias aquelas usinas de energia
das células, lembram? E se você é
daqueles que vive cansado ou cansada,
sem pique para nada, essa forma pode ser
sua melhor amiga. A Denusil é
responsável por transformar gorduras e
proteínas em ATP, que é a moeda de
energia do nosso corpo. É como se ela
fosse um mecânico que faz o motor do
carro funcionar melhor, entende? Por
isso ela é tão procurada por atletas e
pessoas com fadiga crônica. Quando a
mitocôndria tá bombando, você sente a
diferença do dia a dia. E a
hidroxicobalamina,
essa é interessante, ela é como se fosse
a forma crua da vitamina B12, produzida
naturalmente pelas bactérias. O nosso
corpo precisa converter ela nas outras
formas para usar. Mas calma que isso não
é ruim. Na verdade, a hidroxicobalamina
tem uma vantagem bacana. Ela gruda nas
proteínas do sangue e fica circulando
por mais tempo no organismo. É como se
fosse uma poupança de B12 que o corpo
vai usando aos pouquinhos. Por isso, ela
é preferida para injeções, especialmente
na Europa. Quando você tem uma
deficiência grave ou problemas de
absorção intestinal, ela é uma excelente
opção. Uma curiosidade boa, a
hidroxicobalamina também funciona como
antídoto para intoxicação por sianeto.
Ela tem uma afinidade danada por essa
toxina e ajuda a neutralizar.
Interessante, né? Como a natureza é
sábia. Agora vem a pergunta de 1 milhão
de dólares. Qual é a melhor forma? Olha,
eu vou ser sincero com vocês, não existe
uma resposta única. É como perguntar
qual que é o melhor carro. Depende. Você
quer velocidade, quer economia, quer
conforto. Cada forma de B12 tem o seu
forte. Se você está buscando suporte
neurológico, melhorar memória,
concentração ou tem aquelas mutações do
gene MTHFR, a metilcobalamina pode ser a
sua primeira escolha. ela já chega
pronta para trabalhar no cérebro e no
sistema nervoso. Agora, se o lance é
energia, disposição, melhorar rendimento
em treinos ou combater aquela fadiga que
não passa, a denosilucobalamina pode ser
o caminho. Ela vai direto trabalhar nas
mitocôndrias, otimizando a produção de
energia. E se você tem deficiência
grave, problemas de absorção ou precisa
de um estoque mais duradouro, a
hidroxicobalamina injeções pode ser a
melhor pedida, ela fica mais tempo
circulando e o corpo vai convertendo
conforme precisa. Sabe o que que muitos
profissionais de medicina funcional
estão fazendo? Combinando, isso é,
usando metilcobalamina junto com
adenozilcobalamina para ter uma
cobertura completa. É como montar um
time de futebol. Você precisa de um bom
goleiro e de bons atacantes, não é
mesmo? As pesquisas mais recentes de
2025 mostram que essa combinação pode
oferecer benefícios sinérgicos. Enquanto
uma cuida do cérebro e sistema nervoso,
a outra turbina produção de energia. É o
melhor dos dois mundos. Uma coisa
importante que eu preciso falar, todas
essas formas são seguras e eficazes para
corrigir deficiência de B12. A diferença
está na estratégia terapêutica, no
objetivo que queremos alcançar. É como
escolher entre diferentes caminhos para
chegar no mesmo destino. Alguns são mais
rápidos para certas situações, outros
mais adequados para outras. E olha que
interessante, o nosso corpo é tão
inteligente que consegue converter uma
forma na outra. A hidroxicobalamina pode
virar metilcobalamina ou
adenosilcobalamina. A metil pode virar
adenosil e vice-versa. é um sistema
super flexível e adaptável. Para
finalizar nosso papo, eu quero deixar
bem claro, a escolha da melhor forma de
B12 deve ser individualizada.
Depende dos seus objetivos, do seu
perfil bioquímico, dos sintomas que você
apresenta, não existe uma fórmula mágica
que serve para todo mundo. O importante
é não deixar faltar essa vitamina
essencial no seu organismo. Seja qual
for a forma escolhida, o fundamental é
manter os níveis adequados. E lembre-se
sempre, nosso corpo é único, nossas
necessidades são individuais. O que
funciona maravilhosamente bem pro seu
vizinho pode não ser o ideal para você.
Espero que agora quando você for na
farmácia, farmacêutico te mostrar as
opções, você já saiba qual escolher
baseado na suas necessidades. E se tiver
dúvidas ainda, procure sempre a
orientação de um profissional capacitado
em medicina funcional ou nutrição, que
vai avaliar o seu caso específico e
indicar a melhor estratégia. Um abraço
grande e até a próxima.